[Music]
we measure milestones and percentiles
and first steps
to try and gain insight into the person
they'll grow into
another day another grey's anatomy
shocker
e.t can confirm jesse williams will be
leaving the series after the
end of season 17. i know
the actor who has played dr jackson
avery on the abc medical drama for
nearly 12
seasons and over 250 episodes
was first introduced midway through the
sixth season
hey come on avery let's go actually
i forgot i have an appointment so an
appointment what appointment
and his exit from the show was revealed
at the end of thursday's episode
which brought back former series regular
sarah drew as dr april keptner
to tie up loose ends and give jackson a
satisfying farewell
you okay
it's hard to say
but it looks like i'm moving to boston
[Music]
so fingers crossed for new horizons
fingers crossed for new horizons the 39
year old actor's
final episode of grace titled tradition
will air
may 20th in a statement to et grey's
showrunner krista vernov said quote
jesse williams is an extraordinary
artist and activist
watching his evolution these past 11
years both on screen and off
has been a true gift as for jesse
he also released a statement expressing
that he will quote
forever be grateful for the experience
adding quote
i am immensely proud of our work our
impact
and to be moving forward with so many
tools opportunities
allies and dear friends we worked really
hard i was really proud of the work that
everybody did
since the actor joined grace he's
branched off from working in front of
the camera
to directing and producing he's directed
three episodes of the hit medical drama
as well as an episode of abc's drama
series
rebel jesse also produced the academy
award-winning short
two distant strangers which took home
the oscar for live-action short film
this year
and when e.t caught up with jesse in
february he played coy about those
rumors that this season
could be the last adding that shooting a
season of the show with the stressors of
the pandemic
wasn't exactly an ideal way to go out
i think the show is too important to
go out without a damn parade you know
without us
really knowing and having a real finale
season
these writers are so overworked and
pressed and in a rat race to try to get
material out without without all this
uncertainty that's not the ideal
scenario i think we
they they and all of us kind of deserve
to have the time and space to map out
and maybe all of that is just a flowery
way of saying i really hope not
he also hinted at thursday's blast from
the past
saying he'd like to explore jackson's
relationship with his
estranged father played by eric roberts
i was convinced you were better off
without me without a father
how would you think i'm better off
without
my father i think i'd love to
learn more about what it is to live
without that level of parenting in your
life and what it does to you
and i think kind of completing the loop
it did feel like it you know it meant
some resolution but these are things you
know the role i learned from you know
the more more therapy you're in the more
you learn that how much your parents
your parents impact you
and um you know there's a lot to unpack
there in terms of how it has impacted
his sense of identity and motivation
and um uh self-esteem and it was really
great to work with eric roberts
um a hell of a person and an actor i'd
love i'd love to see him and my
you know my mom i'd love to do a little
more of that because
you know out of this personal stuff as
actors you want to get on the inside and
work from the inside out
and a lot of times you know our material
reveals something that was that lies
inside but it's also really fun for us
all
to get into the heart of the heart of
the matter
[Music]
you